Michigan could become the first state to
remove all lead pipes for drinking water
under new regulations that are stricter
than federal standards the Safe Drinking
Water Act calls for the replacement of
500,000 lead service lines for drinking
water across Michigan the process will
start in 2021 and take around 20 years
it follows the water crisis in Flint
that began four years ago when the city
started drawing water from the Flint
River as a cost-saving measure the water
was improperly treated and led leach
from city pipes right into people's
homes exposing thousands of people to
the toxic metal Flint has replaced more
than six thousand lead pipes but nearly
ten thousand are left the state insists
the water quality is restored major and
ideas returned to Flint to see why many
people are still worried about how led
is affecting their children's
development for the first years of their
little lives
siblings Gabby and Connor drank led
contaminated water in their baby formula
and sippy cups their grandmother Laurie
frost didn't know it was tainted but
knew something was wrong
Connor didn't talk he didn't sit upright
he was too and he was only saying three
words
Gabby also struggled with speech and
balance and their doctor pointed to the
water was it hard for you to hear that
he'd been making their bottles with
water that was tainted that's Howard
because I feel like they've been
poisoned nearly two years after the
height of the water crisis the state
says the water is safe but a crisis of
trust remains do you drink the tap water
no do you cook with tap water no because
I don't trust the water but she does
trust this place
Cummings great expectations a preschool
designed only for children exposed to
lead administrator Amy Hess says
developmental delays are widespread do
you think the delays are tied to lead I
don't think anyone can say that's for
sure but I would tell you my years of
experience tell me a group of children
this size has never had this many delays
the 144 children here a fraction of the
5,000 in need get more individual
attention and speech and physical
therapy families also received support
this is trauma this is trauma the
children were exposed to a poison they
can't sell their home they're afraid of
where they live frost celebrates her
grandkid successes but the road ahead
remains long and lonely because she says
the nation has forgotten about Flint for
CBS this morning Adriana Diaz in a
recent letter the governor's advisor on
Flint Richard Baird said the lead levels
there now are even lower than both the
federal standards and limits set for
bottled water he says their findings are
supported by independent scientists